one half of the team here at the st.
Louis chess club who's made that all
possible is co-founder Rex Sinquefield
who is with Maurice to talk about this
new incredible tournament named after
his wife Rex Sinquefield who has done
more for American chess arguably than
maybe anyone in history Rex
thanks so much for being on the show
could you have imagined how
scintillating the play would be here as
the Karen's Cup has been going on it's
just been simply an incredible show it
has been amazing but in fairness the
three of you forecast that on the first
day you said we're gonna have a lot of
decisive games and we have we've had I
think 51 for 52 percent of the games
have been decisive here where compared
to the same field cup that was eight out
of 48 16 percent well last year sing
fill cup at least you know Jeanie Singh
field your your wonderful wife said
there's a little competition going on
between the two of you and I think she's
won this one in her tournament so far
might be a bit more maybe more
interesting than yours well they're
always interesting when you get more
decisive battles and this is probably
the first tournament that has measured
up in quality to the quality of our
three broadcasters now that's tough for
a tournament to do you have to admit but
no it's been really exciting and you
couldn't ask for a better ending where
the last game is decisive for first
place did you guys fix all that I mean
this is so magical the way it's going
you know like the Emperor said in Star
Wars I have foreseen it there more
tournaments to come yeah the grand
chester has expanded and of course
that's going to be all the excites an
incredible expansion you have to really
thank garry kasparov for all of his work
and doing that around the world thank
goodness we have them on our side
working for this event and this event
next year you know we'll have more time
the women will have more chances to
decide and some of those who couldn't
come might be able to come so this event
is
only going to get a lot better over the
years and another event right after this
one the commentators don't get a break
maybe a couple of days and we're back in
business as the champion showdown is
going to happen and look at all these
new names that will be coming to the
club dude a Harry Krishna Navarro or
poor and Dominguez represented the u.s.
for the first time yes I mean that's
really amazing
and the reason you folks don't get a
break is you're so good I mean you got
to play you're a team every time just
like Ben's on right Jennifer's interview
during the break I don't think there's
enough money in women's chess yet is
that and I really am determined to
change that we certainly appreciate that
and speak to that the effect you want to
have and you and Jeannie want to have on
women's chess because that's an area
that's so right for full expansion no it
really is and this is this is a horrible
phrase that's been used in economics
pejoratively but here there really is a
trickle-down effect if we get stronger
top tournaments men and women the
children are going to see that and
they're going to be influenced because
the chess players become their heroes
very understandably and more kids and
more girls will go into chess and we all
know the benefits of it there's no
downside there's only positive benefits
for kids taking part in chess and I
think expanding the number of women's
events increasing the pot size all goes
to help that absolutely well we
certainly appreciate your vision as well
as your wife and obvious leadership
that's made this club into the
world-class club that it is in
destination thanks so much for being